the housing market is not crashing it's
by Dave Ramsey inflation recession High
interest rates High fuel costs labor
market disruption including the great
resignation supply chain shortages bear
Market
and the hits just keep coming are we
heading for the end of American economy
is the housing market going to crash is
this generation going to be priced out
of the housing market and never be
homeowners no no no three no's so that's
three notes so that means he's saying no
two are we headed to the end of American
economy of course not is the housing
market going to crash that's the
question that we want to address the
second one says is this generation going
to be priced out of the housing market
and never be homeowners that's also no I
agree with that one the main one I want
to Target is the middle one is the
housing market going to crash he said no
sorry to end your fear porn party but
the sky is really not falling it's
definitely scary and some of the things
going on truly do suck but the sky's not
falling when you're operating on fear
fight or flight chemicals flood your
brain and your critical thinking skills
shut down higher thought patterns and
Analysis are only possible when a
perceived threat is lowered you don't
ever make good decisions based on
thinking you do when you're afraid or
angry and the new cycle right now will
make you both angry and Afraid several
times a day if you let the drama in so
the porn party is still going so
basically yeah so no what he's saying is
don't worry about it it's all going to
be all right so I'm I just finished a
book it's called how to my default it's
by Jim Collins okay Jim Collins wrote a
book years ago called good to great so
in this book uh how to Mighty Fall he
makes a he asks a very very good
question okay which is a rebuttal to
this here because it is a battle he make
he's he's he's giving the motivational
positive thinking everything's gonna be
all right mindset which is something I
subscribe to my entire life however
there's a caveat to it
in the book Jim Collins says you have
two options here okay say you're
somebody who is always optimistic and
you say things like I'm the best I'm
great we're gonna do fantastic we know
what we're doing we're the best in the
marketplace no one's better than us
we're gonna go do this okay and then the
other mindset is what the mindset of
person says I don't know if I'm good
enough to compete man I don't know if I
have what it takes to compete in the
podcast I don't know if I don't know if
what if the rates drop in real estate
and what if that happens and what if I'm
not good enough to be a father what if
I'm not good enough to be a husband or a
mother or a wife or what if I'm what if
I don't have the goodies here but man I
if I don't call that person what if that
client changes their mind so you're
always in that I'm not good enough to
get to the next level right he says two
companies have two different types of
leaders say one is thinking like
everything's gonna be great and the
other one is dude we got a lot of we got
some improving to do right he says let's
look at the first option if the first
option if you're right guess what
everything's great
if you're wrong
you're problematic you're going to go
out of business
but in the second situation if you're
wrong who cares but if you're right good
for you you're going to keep improving
meaning if you look at this and you say
oh is the market going to crash nah it's
not going to Mark and the Market's not
going to crash
yeah it's gonna be all right don't even
sweat it all this stuff okay then rates
come up okay
to 6.29 percent I don't know if you saw
the Yahoo finance thing I'm gonna send
this to you so you can show it because I
think it's very important for us to see
this
luxury home pricing I'll text this to
you we have it in the article as well
but Tyler if you want to look at your
phone I'm sending it to you uh receive
that one and I'll send you the other one
as well you guys have to see this here
on what the numbers of luxury as well as
uh I'll send you this other one as well
pull these two up if you can pull both
of them up if you can okay so that's one
of them take a look at this this is from
Yahoo finance
this is luxury home sales sink most on
record
that's from 2013. okay look at the
luxury Market it goes down a little bit
in 2014 then in 2020 it drops during
covet dramatically but as bad as it
dropped during covid look how bad it's
dropped after Colvin so meaning covet
was fake it's all fear that six-month
period right there in 2020 2020 that was
not a real crash the market still went
up but look at the drop from the top to
the bottom that is a 28 drop from June
to August highest in 10 years we're
talking about okay so then outside of
that inventory is officially up okay
inventory is going up mortgage rates if
you got the mortgage rates I sent you I
don't know if you got that one as well
if you want to go to the next one I just
sent you take a look at this one here
it's not slowing down go to the next one
ask you a really quick question why is
it because I think you're going there
right now luxury dropped that much what
about just regular regular homes luxury
luxury went up too much and it was
overpriced and now how people are not
willing to pay as many different reasons
they can look at but look at this one
right here rates from 2021 till today
2.85 to 6.29 and it's constantly gone up
the 30 year is 6.29 15 years 5.44 and
the five-year arm is 4.97 so the concept
of fear Point here's a part then then
people say well does this mean the the
bear Market is here is this the end of
it is this like Pat what's going to
happen next let me show you this other
one here and then we'll do some
commentary
I'm going to read the Dao hits bear
Market as stocks sell off okay if you
want to go to page five uh Tyler if you
have that article if not I'll just read
it to the audience this is very
important to pay attention to
okay so down here it's bear Market as
stock sell-off goes from bad to worse
the Dow average on Friday briefly hit a
bear Market before bouncing back from
slightly a 700 point to drop the average
is now sitting at the lowest since
November 2020 which is covet this is the
S P 500 NASDAQ Composite Raptor second
High straight week of losses retreating
to June lows the payment pain may
continue following the Federal Reserve
75 basis point rate hike and new
projected 4.4 percent Federal fund rate
a percentage Point higher than initial
forecast the team at Goldman Sachs led
by David costen cut their cut their
Outlook of the S P 500 this year by 16
to 3600 versus a prior of 4300 as the
economy faces the likelihood of sharp
downturn or hard Landing
when you see numbers like this atom what
do you think about what do you think
about what Dave Ramsey talking about the
you know real estate's not going to
crash and then you see the market
dipping 28 specifically on real estate
how do you process that I mean I'm
looking from a macro perspective I think
I mean the world has changed so much in
the last two years right I mean I think
everything we've gone through with covid
and the markets and real estate and
masks and lockdowns and and recessions
and this that I think everyone
is looking for stability at this point
so there's so many people saying I know
that the Market's going to go up
Market's not going to go down this is
what happened with Kobe this is what's
going on in the world economic Forum
like there's so many different things
going on and I think it's incumbent on
you as an individual to seek stability
in your life there's going to be experts
telling you XYZ up down left right yeah
I think it's very important for you as
an individual to take ownership in your
life and say how the can I make my life
better and tune out the noise we're
literally going through a hurricane
right now like in Florida and I feel
like the entire world from a to use a
metaphor is going through a financial uh
social socio-economic hurricane and in
the middle of this crazy storm that's
going on you you know the calm and the
eye of the storm is the is the only
place in the middle of a hurricane where
there's actually not craziness going on
so in all the craziness of the world you
need to figure out where that stability
can come from in your life whether
that's God whether that's family whether
that's politics whether that's just you
know your own individual freedoms
whatever it is you need to find that
certain to your life I don't know if
Ramsay's right I don't know if he's
wrong I don't know if Jamie diamonds are
right I don't know if he's wrong but you
need to kind of find the voice of reason
in your life and find your center of
gravity and figure it out for yourself
because nobody's coming to save you you
got to save yourself
great great I love the the fear porn
conversation though um just because I
feel like we've seen that explode so
much in society over the last two years
and fear has played a role in people's
Health decisions where people live how
they live it's had a huge impact on the
way parents raise children now you have
a lot of kids that are growing up afraid
of literally everything because their
parents are now afraid of everything
because they've been through coven and
it's affecting Society at large in so
many ways it affected the way the school
system runs so people are in a very
different head right now and I'm
wondering if there's just going to be a
pretty enormous backlash to this which
means that a lot of people were making
decisions based on fear and now are
looking back and seeing the negative
ramifications of that on them themselves
and their families and I'm wondering if
now there's going to be people rising up
refusing to do that again with the
complete opposite uh mindset of I'm not
going to live in fear I'm not going to
let these things you know prevent me
from excelling I'm not going to be you
know stymied by what a political
bureaucrat or what Society tells me I
should be afraid of because what I'm
seeing now is kind of like a a lion kind
of like Roar from a lot of people who
bought into the fear and now just refuse
to live that way just seeing how
negatively it affected their families
over the course the last two years so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]